this is how I would conclude Stargate
Universe welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
now last week Jay made a video with his
theory on how they would save the crew
of the Destiny or at least what the
outcome for them would be if a new
Stargate show was green lit and it was
pretty dark this however is how I would
conclude Stargate Universe so sit back
relax and enjoy
Eli manages to ration the food and water
eating just enough to survive while
simultaneously thinking of ways to fix
the last pod
he isn't successful in fixing the Pod
however he was able to figure out a way
of interacting with the gate causing a
glitch that meant he would be stored in
the gates buffer releasing him just
before the buffer is erased and then
taken some time in between to figure out
everything he could about the destiny he
does this over a period of a few years
until Destiny finally reaches the other
Galaxy
the destiny stops in the solar system
very similar to Earth where he is able
to find food and water enough to keep
the crew going for many months he's able
to top up the air filters replenish the
water supplies and although he now has a
surplus he sticks to a strict rationing
he tends to do this for a few months
until he is sure he's in a position to
wake up some of the crew
he first wakes up Colonel young who is
surprised to see Eli has lost a lot of
weight and asks how long it's been Eli
tells him five years
the rest of the crew are still in stasis
and Destiny is just about to enter a
start to refuel Eli tells young that he
knows where in the universe they are
thanks to the master code from Rush
Eli's had a long time to study the
destiny and he's confident he can turn
the ship around
young makes contact with Earth via the
communication stones
the SGC now headed by General Carter is
very surprised to see them
they've always kept someone on post just
in case but they were starting to lose
hope
Eli never used the stones
not even once asks Young
no we lost contact five years ago we
thought the pods had failed and we've
been working on a way to get to Destiny
response Carter in the five years since
going into stasis Earth has been playing
around with the Wormhole drive from
Atlantis and they're developing a
prototype for their new class of ship
the BC 306 Horizon
306 young asks
yes we've made significant progress in
upgrading Earth's Fleet in the past five
years we've had multiple BC 305s and the
BC 306 is our latest and greatest
equipped with a wormhole Drive
the only problem is without knowing
exactly where you are it's going to be
like finding a needle in a haystack
young interrupts Eli Eli has had five
years and he knows our exact coordinates
young continues he's also confident he
can turn the ship around
young returns to Destiny to tell Eli the
good news and gives the order to wake
everyone up
Eli is elated the thought of Home seeing
his mother is what's kept him going all
this time
what about Rush ask Eli
what about him young asks
well
I know how to turn the ship around but
Rush isn't going to be very happy if we
abandoned Destiny's Mish young
interrupts Eli we have been stocking
those pods for five damn years I could
give a rat's ass what rush thinks in
fact make sure he is the last person out
I want to see this Mission through and
I'm not letting him get in the way of
getting these people home
Eli begins to periodically revive the
crew telling each of them about the plan
whilst Rush remains in stasis the crew
celebrate and ask Eli about his time
whilst they've been in stasis he
explains how he managed to survive All
This Time by using the gate and tells
them all the Amazing Discoveries he's
made about the ship did you know there's
a whole separate compartment filled with
Stacy's pods that we didn't even see Eli
explains
why don't you get into one of them
Lieutenant Scott asks
well you're not gonna believe this
they're already occupied
lantian scientist I assume I didn't want
to revive them because well I know I
could be grouchy after a long nap but
these guys have been in there for
millions of years
wait you're telling me there was a crew
aboard the ship this entire time and we
never knew asked Scott
yep seems that way reading the ship's
earliest logs I figured they were
probably put there to revive as soon as
Destiny reached the signal young walks
in over here in a conversation
well we're not gonna be around for that
day I've just been in contact with
General Carter
General Scott exclaims yes Lieutenant
it's been a long time
you're telling me Scott replies
young continues The Horizon is scheduled
to be with us in three months which
means we have a lot of time to kill
thanks to Mr Wallace here we have enough
food and water to survive for six months
so now all we do is wait
the crew cheer and celebrate
let's revive rush and tell him the plan
if he wants to stay he's more than
welcome but in three months time we're
getting on that ship and we're leaving
Young tells Eli
three months later
the BC 306 Horizon arrives in a distant
Galaxy they find the destiny make
contact and get the crew on board
Rush instead of returning to Earth with
the others Ops to sit in the ancient
chair uploading his Consciousness to
Destiny's computer
at least you'll get to discover what the
Ancients couldn't young says
as the Horizon veers away from the
destiny edai looks out of one of the
observation decks a tear on his cheek
we're going home
and that is how I would conclude
Stargate Universe let me know what you
think of it in the comment section down
below if you did enjoy this video make
sure you hit subscribe and once you
download press like and also consider
becoming a fully fledged side tracker by
pressing the join button
you can follow me on Twitter as well my
Twitter is Matt the dean but with all
that being said I hope you really
enjoyed this video and I will see you in
another one take care guys
[Music]